subaru of las vegas the sponsors of this
next segment is always pouring into this
community and sharing the love take a
look
so the subaru share the love event has
been going on this will be our 14th year
to do the share the love event and it
has been such an amazing experience
where
we are able to connect with local and
national charities and customers who
come in during the period and this year
it'll be november 18th to january 3rd
when they purchase or lease a new subaru
subaru will donate 250
to a charity of their choice amongst the
ones that they have nationally and
locally and then we add another fifty
dollars to our local charities and we're
also adding five dollars for every oil
change that we do so it's just a great
way to raise a lot of money
and actually they've raised over 200
million dollars over the past 13 shared
love of love events and hopefully we'll
reach
225 million this year so the national
charities are the aspca
meals on wheels
make a wish and the national parks
foundation all great charities we have
two local charities hometown charities
that we are supporting red rock search
and rescue is our legacy charity we've
had them from the very beginning what a
great organization all volunteers most
of them first responders and they not
only go up into red rock in the
mountains and looking for hikers that
might be lost but they do some great
things here in our community with people
there are alzheimer's patients or lost
children
and then the second charity brand new
this year is the just one project a
great community organization that's
doing really neat stuff with feeding
people and these pop-up events that they
do in schools and around the city and
job placement it's just a great
organization we do love the national
charities but of course our heart is
here at home in southern nevada and just
being able to work with these
organizations directly throughout the
year and knowing them personally knowing
the great things they do we want to
encourage everybody that comes in and
buys or leases a new subaru we want to
encourage them to direct those dollars
to southern nevada and of course that
means red rock search and rescue or the
just one project on a personal level
i think it's more blessed to give than
to receive i didn't say that originally
that came from scripture but you know i
i believe it it is it is something that
i hold dear
i really believe that that generous
heart really is something that if we
give more uh we're going to receive more
and that's not the purpose for it but
you know it's what makes the world go go
around you know and so um it's also the
subaru love promise that we are going to
impact our community where we live and
work and and give back and make it a
better place
thank you to subaru of las vegas for
sponsoring this segment call them at
702-490
or visit subaru of las vegas.com they
have a special offer for you as well 0.9
financing for well-qualified buyers for
up to 48 months on select 2021 models
las vegas now we'll be right back